former CEO of Google Eric Schmidt the
internet will disappear Eric Schmidt
president of the company stepping down
from their roles
the date is July of 2001 out of the blue
Larry Page co-founder and CEO of Google
sends a cryptic email summoning all
Google engineers and project managers to
meet outside his office to share some
unexpected news within no time of all
130 of Google's engineers and project
managers would form a huddle around
Page's office anxious what the news
could be did Google get sued by Yahoo
was AOL threatening a hostile takeover
was the company about to run out of
funding as these thoughts raced through
Engineers Minds Paige candidly stepped
out of his office ended with his unusual
hoarse voice he would have firmly
announce that all project managers were
fired effective immediately and all
Engineers were to report to some newly
hired engineer named Wayne rosing
everyone was stunned this wasn't about
the state of Google or the future of the
company this was about the Page's
personal hatred for me managers you see
Paige strongly felt that Google had
hired the best engineers in the world
and that these brilliant individuals
didn't need untactical morons telling
them what to do he felt that Engineers
should be able to choose what they work
on and set their own paces and he was
hoping that Google's Engineers would
agree but to his surprise it was
actually the engineers that would speak
back one engineer named Ron Dolan
snapped back that what the page was
doing was completely ridiculous and
totally unprofessional Paige was
gobsmacked surely other Engineers would
understand the freedom of having no
managers and support The Purge maybe
they just needed a bit of time to adjust
so Paige would end the meeting and hoped
that things would settle down but they
didn't within just a few weeks projects
would start lacking resources redundancy
would fall off a cliff and Engineers
were craving one-on-one feedback from a
direct Superior unsurprisingly VC
funders were pissed and it didn't take
long for HR to step in they would
reinstate all of a Google's fired
project managers and before you knew it
there was someone new on The Chopping
Block co-founder Larry Page a man named
Eric Schmidt was supposed to become the
new CEO and the chairman of Google and
that Larry Page would be relieved of all
duties instead he was to take on a more
advisory role behind Eric Paige was
devastated he had just dependent Steve
Jobs kicked out of his own company and
basically given a Pity role as an
advisor but looking back this was for
the best as Eric Schmidt would take
Google from being a brilliant startup to
being a tech Empire he would lead the
company for the next 10 years and to
make Google the leader in email video
sharing search maps Cloud browsers
mobile and more he would grow a Fortune
of 25 billion dollars for himself as he
spearheaded Google into becoming a multi
100 billion dollar company but almost as
magically as he appeared at Google he
would vanish as this is the story of The
Forgotten CEO that saved Google from its
own founders
Eric Schmidt
while Eric was an outsider he was by no
means unqualified Eric was born in false
Church Virginia on April 27 1955 to two
academics his mother Eleanor had a
masters in Psychology way back in the
1950s and his father was an extremely
well respected economics professor he
not only taught at Virginia Tech and the
John Hopkins University but he would go
on to serve in the U.S treasury under
President Richard Nixon little to say
Eric had a pretty strong background
which allowed him to excel at school and
attend Princeton University there he
would receive a bachelor's in electrical
engineering in 1976 before moving on to
UC Berkeley to get a masters Eric went
on to get a masters in electrical
engineering and computer science in 1979
but it seems that one of his graduate
school projects was even more valuable
than the education itself you see him
Eric would design and Implement a
network called birknet that linked up
the computer centers of 2 Apartments the
Cs department and the eecs department
this project would actually evolve into
becoming a PhD thesis about managing
distributed software development and
Eric would cash in on this PhD in 1982
also from UC Berkeley during his
academic years he would jump around a
bunch of it companies from Bell labs to
xerox's famous Apollo Alto Research
Center but his real career in Tech
didn't start till 1983 when he joins on
Microsystems as their first software
manager this is quite ironic as this was
the exact position that Larry Page was
trying to eliminate at Google 20 years
later but let's just say that Eric would
have more than proved that this position
was more than just a placeholder at Sun
Eric would rise up the ranks like a
madman first being promoted to director
of software engineering before being
promoted to vice president of software
products and then Vice President of
General systems during his 14 years at
Sun Eric oversaw the creation of one of
the most respected empires of the 1990s
now of course Sun would get crushed by
the.com crash and to be completely
forgotten about but that's a whole other
story I guess you could say that it's a
good thing that Eric left at the top in
1997 and it took on a position as CEO
and chairman of Nobel if you're not
familiar with Nobel there were actually
the second the largest producer of
software at one point only beaten out by
Microsoft but by the late 1990s they
were a declining Giant and Eric was
brought in to turn around the company it
seems that he was actually pretty
successful at this as the company was in
a good enough position to acquire some
beaten down.com companies like Cambridge
technology Partners But Eric wasn't able
to get much further than that as right
after this acquisition you would be
called in to babysit Larry Page and
Sergey Brin
[Music]
like Steve Jobs Larry Page and Sergey
Brin were actually able to choose who
would take on the position of CEO and it
was them who chose Eric thankfully for
Google Eric wasn't another John Scully
while Google's bored and investors did
pressure Eric Duran and Larry and Sergey
Eric didn't really give in to this
pressure you see it though Eric was
hired to be a babysitter he felt that it
was much more suitable for him to take
on the role of personal assistant while
Eric was exceptionally qualified it may
be even more qualified than Larry and
Sergey at the time he recognized that it
was not his place to inject his own
vision for the company at the end of the
day this was a Larry and sergey's
company and he was Simply Hired to help
them execute their Vision Without
pissing off the board or investors and
that's exactly what he did after he took
over he would give Larry and Sergey full
freedom to continue leading the company
from a technical and Visionary
standpoint Eric would simply take care
of all of the daily nuances and
obstacles that came along with running
and scaling a startup things like
addressing investors addressing the
board handling public relations dealing
with HR scaling the workforce resolving
conflicts and launching products on time
and on budget basically all of the
boring stuff that comes along with being
CEO but while boring this is the
lifeblood of any company and especially
an up-and-coming startup like Google
also if you have any doubts about it
just how much Freedom Eric gave Valerian
Sergey here's how many Acquisitions went
down at Google Larry and Sergey were to
find something that interested them they
would buy the company and Eric would
find out after everything was said and
done this is actually how Google ended
up with Android and the Google Maps our
regular CEO would probably be quite
bothered by this and rightfully so but
Eric figured that Larry and Sergey were
the most incentivized to not ruin the
company aside from giving Larry and
Sergey space Eric also formed acute
relationships with other tech companies
for example in late 2006 he would join
an Apple's board of directors right
before the launch of the iPhone but
despite all this freedom for the first
few years Larry always had a level of
distrust with Eric I mean after all Eric
was literally hired to replace Larry but
over time Larry would grow comfortable
with the delegating basically everything
that Eric other than the vision Larry
wasn't never a fan of meetings but he
wasn't tend on attending them in the
early days as he wanted to make sure
that Eric didn't overrule his voice but
by 2007 he would stop attending meetings
altogether as he trusted that Eric would
carry out what he wanted and by 2008
Larry would also stop doing interviews
altogether stating that that was what
Eric was for Larry and Eric were getting
along better than the board could have
ever imagined but this golden period it
didn't last forever
foreign
Sergey got to know Eric better they
realized that while he was exceptional
at execution he wasn't a risk taker sure
he was willing to let Larry and Sergey
mess around with Acquisitions and run a
crazy April Fool's Day pranks with the
Gmail and YouTube but when it came to
something that could truly threaten the
company Eric would always choose the
conservative way out and one of the best
examples of this was with chrome chrome
was pretty late to the browser scene
having not been released till late 2008
but this wasn't because Chrome was an
afterthought it was because Eric
wouldn't allow for Chrome Larry and
Sergey had actually pitched Chrome to
Eric for six full years but he always
rejected the idea it wasn't until Larry
and Sergey went behind Eric's back and
secretly developed a chrome prototype
that Eric simply gave up on trying to
stop them now of course Chrome would go
on to be a roaring success so this was
definitely something that Eric got wrong
but it's not what pushed him out what
pushed him out was his stance on China
as you know the CCP and you either play
by their rules or you get out throughout
the early 2000s Eric had worked
painstakingly hard to play by the ccp's
rules and to get Google launched in
China in 2006 but by the late 2000s
China was changing up the rules and they
wanted Google to censor certain topics
well not ideal Eric wasn't more than
happy to do this after all he thought
that it was more important for Google to
stay relevant and what he describes as
the world's largest consumer Marketplace
Larry and Sergey however disagreed they
felt that it was more important for
Google to stick by their motto of don't
be evil and not allow for censorship
larion Sergey would end up getting their
way and Google would leave China in 2010
for the first time Larry felt that Eric
was pulling Google in a different
direction a direction that he didn't
want to go down it quickly became clear
to Larry that it was time for Eric to go
and for himself to take the reins once
again and again that Larry now had a
relatively positive relationship with
the board thanks to Eric he was able to
lobby for himself to become CEO once
again Eric who was quickly approaching
60 didn't really resist he had been
there for nearly 10 years and it felt
like a natural time to move on so he
would leave with remark I believe Larry
is ready I'm sure he'll do a fantastic
job and with that Larry was CEO once
again but the truth was that he wasn't
really ready he felt that the biggest
limiter for Google wasn't managers but
rather shareholders he may have very
well been right but let's just say it's
not a great idea to make shareholders an
enemy as a public CEO Larry would learn
this the hard way and he would only last
SEO for a few years pretty soon he would
promote Sundar piche to CEO leading us
to the modern day Google
foreign
Larry and Sergey truly are The
Visionaries behind Google but their
Visions would have never materialized if
it wasn't for Eric the reality was that
while Larry and Sergey were brilliant
engineers and forward thinkers they just
weren't all that great businessmen and
if it wasn't clear the first time around
it it was definitely clear the second
time around they needed someone to focus
and execute on their ideas and that's
exactly what Eric did to be honest Eric
still had a few good years in him at
Google but I suppose it all worked out
fine anyway all of this talk that Eric
earned during his tenure made him the
72nd richest person in the world with a
net worth of 21 billion dollars but
that's arguably the smallest part of his
legacy did you know about Eric Schmidt
comment that down below also drop a like
if you would like to see more videos
about untold business Legends and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community such as free video ideas and
consider subscribing to more questions
at logical answer but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]